[Applause]
[Music]
I'm John I'm the founder and CEO of
betterment raise your hand if you've
heard of betterment oh my god okay good
so most of you raise your hand if you're
a customer of betterment okay like a
little less I'd like to get that ratio
better but that's not why we're here
today you're here to hear about my
failures and experiences and understand
how those might help you in your own
entrepreneurial journey so I'm excited
to talk about that I'll just say quickly
for context betterment is an online
financial advisor we take all the things
a great financial adviser would do if
you had one and we make them smarter
faster cheaper and better for instance
if you have a bunch of you know expenses
and you've got your direct deposit
coming in and you find yourself trying
to manage your cash flow month-to-month
in your bank account we'll do that for
you automatically will sweep money back
and forth where it needs to be to help
you make the most of it or if you're
planning for your family's retirement or
your kid's college savings will tell you
what accounts to open how much to put in
each of those accounts and keep you on
track to your goals that's what I mean
by financial advice when we when we
started back in the early days I had a
had a belief that I would just kind of
get to think about things and and and
work on the product and my co-founder my
first co-founder Sean used to say what
you have to do John is you have to make
it real as quickly as possible I would
talk about all the things that I wanted
to build and the services that I wanted
to deliver and you'd say you know what
before we can design all these like
these graphs and things you just have to
you have to make a sign up that people
can use and do those basic things print
your business cards and this advice has
stuck with me really more than anything
else I that that I've learned in the in
the past many years when we would go to
pitch
VC's and early advisors and things like
this the thing that made a difference
with them was when we could show them
something tangible right so actually
having a sign-up process that worked and
having a website that we're making it
real for them it wasn't just a concept
but it was a tangible thing made all the
difference in the world and so when
people ask me what's the number one
thing that I should do to get my company
off the ground who do I need to talk to
just go out and make it real make it
happen and and make it something that
people can can touch and feel so people
believe in your story at that time I was
doing everything by myself
I was I was coding I would I would get
into these like 24 hour you know almost
trance-like states of just trying to
perfect a certain part of the site and I
loved that time right like that flow
that you get into when you're really
working on something that you're
passionate about and and and I was doing
the engineering I bought like 40 legal
books about securities regulation and
derivatives and all of the things that
I'd have to know to set up a regulated
financial entity it was too much I took
on everything and over time I I realized
that I wasn't going to be able to do
everything by myself and I started
talking to friends and those friends
started wanting to join up and sign up
and help me and what I learned early on
was the role of a founder is to try to
have nothing to do you've got to build a
team you've got to find other people who
can take all that work off of you just
this week I was talking to one of my
senior team members and I said to her
you know like this is gonna sound crazy
but if I have work to do it's a really
bad thing right you don't want to be
relying on me for this deliverable right
we've got to find somebody else to do
this it takes an amazing team and you
have to constantly be delegating we
found you know fortunately people came
to us over the years
and the reason that they came to us was
primarily for the mission from day one I
was talking about how I wanted to change
the world I wanted to build financial
services around the customer in a way
that they hadn't been done before and
that mission that idea of changing a
really broken industry resonated with
people and that's why amazing people
like Danny again or Alex pinky or all of
our our team came to join us and left
great jobs in you know big financial
services companies where they had great
incomes and a lot of job security they
came for the mission and to me that that
mission is the one thing about
betterment that hasn't changed this is
something I feel like we we got right
from the beginning having a mission is
so critical I believe to building your
business in attracting talent and
attracting capital and that passion that
you feel about the mission is going to
come through in every one of your
conversations I see many of you smiling
and nodding you feel that you know it
and don't be afraid of that conviction I
feel like some people it won't resonate
with them right like they're gonna be
like you're a little crazy like what are
you doing but I think the right people
are gonna be attracted to that passion
and they're going to join your cause and
that's gonna serve you for years to come
you got to hang on to that I've been
doing this 10 years now I've been
building betterment for a long long time
and it's been the majority of my
professional career at this point an
amazing spot to to learn a lot about
growing and running a business but it
takes constant energy to do that and one
of the things that really keeps me going
is coming back to the mission coming
back to why I started that's coming back
to our customers and that that helps
drive me forward as well
I mentioned that mission is important
and customers are important customers is
the is the other thing that really keeps
me going
just over Thanksgiving I was home in
Dallas where I'm from with my parents
and and I had coffee with a couple of
customers their betterment we do this
program where we send out emails to
people in our hometowns and a lot of the
product and marketing teams do this I I
got so much energy from these
conversations
since it was it's amazing to connect
with like real like random people you
don't know and and hear their stories
and in this case it was great because
they they had no issues with the service
they were like right you know just mega
fans right they were so excited to be
talking with me and sharing what they
wanted to see on the platform that was
new and they they loved the high
interest smart saver account and they
loved the account aggregation and so on
it was great and I brought that energy
back to the team now we do lots of
things at betterment to try to build
customers into everything that we do we
do customer week where every single
person in the company is on the phones
with our customers this is a bit of a
throwback to the early days when
literally was a room of you know four to
ten people as we scaled and at that time
we had no customer service and there was
just a phone tree and it was sort of
like ring it one person's desk and then
ringing the next person's desk and we
would see like you know how long we
could wait like with the phone's ringing
before somebody picked it up but I was
talking to all the customers back in
those days and we all were and we all
had this very close relationship with
them and I loved that and and when
someone was on the phone of the customer
if they had a problem you knew because
you're in the same room with them and
and so you'd hear what customers needed
from us all the time as we've scaled
we're now almost 250 people and we're no
longer all on the same floor we're not
even all in the same building and it's
harder now to keep in touch with our
customers I get to do it because I can
go and sit with the customer experience
team anytime I want and and I still do
customer week and all that but a lot of
our team doesn't have that same access
in like and memory and and an ability to
connect so my new year's resolution for
2018 was to bring the customer to life
within betterment
we've done so much more this year to
research our customers we've done more
surveys more panels more getting out
there and I just I think to me this is
all back to basic stuff but it's a
reminder to me of how important it is
because I felt like as we were growing
we're getting further and further from
the reason we're doing this we were
getting further from our customer
in the early days we didn't have to do
panels because like like many of you who
are hustling and entrepreneurial we were
constantly ourselves out talking to
customers and I just I can't
overemphasize the importance of that and
those insights and cataloging them and
acting on them you have a great instinct
if you're talking to your customers all
the time one of our values at betterment
is is iterate to breakthrough we have
this concept of constantly trying to
improve things and I boil that down into
this lesson of never settle I think it's
possible to get to a spot where you feel
like things are pretty good and the
product is working and maybe maybe
you're you're dominant in the market or
you don't see any competition but it's
coming I personally can tell you like
we've been at this for 10 years now
where the market leader in the space and
every year there are new entrants
there's new competition there's new
people coming after us and they're doing
interesting things and you got to keep
your eyes open and continue to iterate
and improve as a founder you'll you'll
appreciate that you're never quite
satisfied with what you've got always
want it to be better right you're
thinking you've got this long list of
things and you may talk to people in
your customers and they may say I love
your product and I bet sometimes when
you hear that you think oh it's it
should be so much better if not if not
what I want it to be yet and that that
drive to improve you're going to feel
that more than your customers are going
to feel that you're going to feel that
more than your team is going to feel
that you have to help all of them feel
that you have to paint for them the
vision of what could be and how much
better the service could be and
constantly drive to improve it and
iterate and make it better we have
another value our first value is pursue
happiness
it's a little bit of a funny you know
construction and pursue happiness and
and and what it means to us is that
we're constantly striving we're
constantly going after something that we
may never fully attain but we enjoy that
struggle we enjoy the journey and we
enjoy struggling together that idea
pursuing happiness is about struggling
and striving and I think it comes back
to this this concept of not settling and
always trying for more and that's been
an important part of how we've continued
to innovate and iterate and grow there's
a counterpoint to that which is that you
can constantly trying to do all these
things and never get anything done
and so the the last point I want to make
on lessons that I've learned or things
that I feel like we could do better is
prioritization is key I'm terrible at
this I always want to do everything and
my team in every planning cycle has to
tell me John we can't possibly do all of
that you realize we're gonna break the
company if we try and do this many
things we don't have that big of a team
we're you know we're already doing too
much what can we stop doing and so we've
tried different approaches of you know
stopping things and and and they try to
contain me but I just have this desire
to do so much I mean we're in the the
retail business we're in the b2b
business we support advisers we're now
doing cash management we've got all this
personalization I'm just always trying
to do more and you know a little bit
this comes back to hiring a great team
and finding people who can can support
you in those areas where you're less
strong I have a great a great management
team who do contain me in this area and
and you know can talk to me and tell me
like what's actually possible
we've got great product managers and
project managers and product marketers
who help us to strictly prioritize
manage things and make sure that they
get done I can't emphasize enough how
important it is to to focus and without
that focus and drive on what's actually
most important we never would have
gotten anywhere and those are my very
simple lessons or learnings I should say
from my past past 10 years at betterment
and the things that have helped to drive
us forward and and I love to to take
your questions about anything that I've
talked about today or anything about the
the business or other things that that
we've learned so should we be worried
about the yield curve wow this is this
is pretty wonky I have a really generic
answer to all of these kinds of market
questions people say what about China or
you know that's something different
every week if you're invested for the
for your goals if you're thinking about
the if you're invested for what's really
important to you like if your goal is
retirement that's probably 30-plus years
out for for many people in this room if
you're invested for you know down
payment on a house that you got to make
next year you're going to invest that
money really differently you're gonna
put that into into a savings account or
a high-yield money market or something
and as long as you're invested for the
right duration for your goals you don't
have to worry about the news the news is
there to scare you and grab your
attention and make you you know do
things you shouldn't do it's not there
to help you make the right decision and
as a financial advisor I just constantly
come back to the idea that make sure
your your investments or align with your
goals and you're going to be fine you
don't have to worry about this kind of
stuff I frankly think it's crazy that we
live in a world where all of you are
expected to be financial experts it's
like if the dumbest thing you know we we
have 401ks now and so you have to think
about you know how you're invested for
your retirement
but this is this is like not something
that everyone has time to do it's as
though I said you should be responsible
for your own health care you can have
any drug you want have as much as you
want there's no doctors good luck
that's just like a dumb way that you
never design a health care system that
way but that's how our financial system
basically works it's like here's a bunch
of bad products go have whatever you
want you know like good luck
I believe the future of our industry of
financial services designed around
customers designed around real people is
that you all and I most of it including
myself shouldn't have to worry about
this stuff that that we there should be
intelligence that helps to manage your
wallet that helps you to put the next
dollar in the right place to make the
most of it anyway that's what we're
building and that's that's my long
answer to should you be worried about
the yield curve how do you find the
balance between motivating your team to
want to be do better and celebrating
your team successes I love to celebrate
successes I I think marking occasions is
a must we have a lot of traditions at
betterment and we celebrate occasions
all the time we have we have these
traditions I feel like help to help to
build the culture they also help to let
the team know how much you care about
the team so we have four tentpole events
we do our anniversary party every May we
launched it TechCrunch Disrupt in May of
2010 and so that's our ante party we do
a Thanksgiving which is most people's
favorite event where it's a potluck and
everyone comes and and and brings their
own dishes and brings their families and
so on and then we do summer and winter
retreats we go skiing for a day in the
winter and we do like a camp camp thing
in the summer I really value this kind
of stuff I think it's so important to
get the team together to get out of the
office to see each other in a different
context one of our values is build
relationships beyond the tasks what that
means build relationships beyond the
tasks of course if you're like in a
project together you have to get to know
someone
but go beyond that go outside of it get
to know them beyond the way that you
work with them to me that's important to
building a strong team where you have
people you can go back to and people who
will come to you even if you don't have
an immediate need from them I think
that's an important part of building a
great company when we when we think
about traditions we also do things like
the betterment of betterment Awards
where we have seven or seven values and
we have seven paths one that goes with
each of the values so like you know our
value of embraced efficiency is one of
those hats with like the drinking straws
you know for like the beers up top
because it's an efficient way to drink
beer I guess I think that having in that
recognition and we celebrate people who
represent each one of those values I
think that's an important way to to
perpetuate your company's values and
culture how much capital have you raised
and why did you choose venture yeah
listen I I have a ton respect for people
who bootstrap businesses I think it's an
amazing way to go if you if you've got
that kind of kind of a business and that
kind of a drive where you can can
achieve that do it
I knew starting out that to build a
financial services brand that would
reach millions of customers we would
have to raise Bo loads of money like I
just I had looked I looked at all the
examples of people who'd built financial
brands and like no one had done it for
less than hundreds of millions of
dollars right so I looked at Schwab I
looked at ing you know you look at all
these good so and so we we set out
knowing that it would require capital it
end up requiring a lot more capital than
even I thought I mean we've raised two
hundred and eighty million dollars to
date we
we still have a lot of that in the bank
we continue to to grow and invest it but
when I think about why did we raise it
it was just it was we had to do it what
was important to me was finding the
right kinds of partners in raising it so
there's like there's there's all kinds
of inter capitalists out there they all
have somewhat similar motivations but
you know when you talk to someone if
they share your values and if they share
your aspirations and hopes for the
company are our first venture investor I
always talk talk about our first meeting
was love at first pitch as we went out
to the the best of our offices and we
sat down with Rob's Davis who's still on
my board today and I told him about the
vision for betterment and what we wanted
to do in the mission that I talked about
earlier of helping customers to do
what's best with their money so they can
live better and he said that's great
we've been looking for a company like
this for two years and this is the best
one I've seen I'd love to be in business
together they had a long term horizon
he's been invested for for eight years
now and isn't talking at all about you
guys should think about you know
liquidity or you should be you know
moving to find a buyer because they have
a very long term horizon at Bessemer and
that's the thing that was important to
me in finding the right kind of partner
all of our investors share that same
long-term view and and that's important
to us there are other reasons to hire
other investors that obviously doesn't
make that right for everyone some have
great expertise in retail distribution
or or other networks so so I chose
venture because I knew we need capital
and patient capital it would take a long
time how did you choose your team early
on how did they stick around do they
volunteer intern or did you pay them my
poor early team we my my co-founder Eli
and I didn't didn't pay
self salaries for at least a year and a
half in the early days we really we went
through all of our savings we'd put a
lot of our savings into the company
we hired a couple of a couple of friends
I mean my my colleague from FMCG Anthony
joined us and and then we hired a CTO
Kiran who I knew through the Columbia
Network we paid them not enough you know
it was it was well below market like a
quarter of what they've been making and
we paid them in equity and then after
they worked for us for like nine months
we said so we're gonna run out of money
and it would be great if you guys could
put in some money so that we can
continue to pay you and you know
fortunately they did so we were really
lucky to have people who were passionate
about the mission and believed in it as
much as I did and they helped us to to
get through equity is something that we
give to every employee of betterment I I
think it's part of aligning the team
around the around the vision and the
mission and with that I want to say
thank you so much for having me here
it's a great honor to go
[Applause]